okay everyone after new rockstars broke
down the trailer for ant-man in the wasp
recently upon re-watching it we realized
there were even more super interesting
details that please some it's the first
time so if you haven't already go back
and watch the breakdown but here are
four additional Easter eggs are you
ready
yes okay well first early on there's a
shot of Pimm's new vessel warming up in
its lab and if you look to the right
side you can see a giant Duracell
battery now this is probably being used
as him as an energy source to power his
lab which is probably how he's able to
move it portably in that rollaway
building it's just battery powered next
there are a lot of shots of Scott and
hope inside a Pym technology equipped
van which can resize with all the
contents and passengers inside of that
van and some of you guys pointed out to
me that this could be the MC used
version of the ant van from the comics
it's customized Vance Scott Lang mix or
ant-man security solutions it basically
looks like a terminators to our
exterminators truck terminator it kind
of seems yeah now for this next one I
feel a little dumb for missing this at
first but when Scott becomes the giant
man version himself and looms out of the
bay over the ferry looking down at sunny
birch birches clutching that miniature
eyes rolled away building that we saw
Hanks shrink down or earlier I know it's
good obvious I just I guess that's what
he's after
you know PIMs entire lab building I mean
I guess if it's that small why not try
to steal the whole thing right and then
finally in the close up of ghosts hands
as she revs her motorcycle you can see a
container with some gold colored serum
now I'm thinking ghosts could be using
the serum to trigger her intangibility
phase shifting allowing her and perhaps
her bike to pass through surfaces and
objects during this high-speed chase now
yeah you guys are at some of these
details seem a little silly and
practical a blown up battery being used
as a generator a building with a
slide-out handle and wheels does this
stuff seem too goofy for you guys or
would you like to see it man the sequel
go more in this direction oh man I don't
don't make giant Pez is all I want to
eat a giant Pez I want to know what
that's like
here's the question for you guys did he
build a giant retractable handle with
giant wheels and put those on the
building or did he build the building
shrink it put those in there make it big
again and then hide it I think he built
the miniaturized version first because
if a building is made of like drywall
and steel and all these like it wouldn't
things in there if you were to just like
cut out part of it it's not like a cake
that you're gonna slice down in the
middle and like put like frosting inside
it's like the whole thing's gonna start
to fall apart if you start to like cut a
hole inside of it you're cutting away
like a huge chunk of the building either
you might as well just build it small
like an atrium like they just build a
building they leave holes and then he
shrinks it and then he puts rods through
it and then he expands it again I think
it'd just be way easier to start with a
dollhouse and make it big there you go I
mean there's options here I think he
built it shrunk it put those in there
made it again and then he just was wake
it's weighted if he built a doll house
II think there's like subtlety to the
desks in there and stuff you think
they're just like popsicle sticks that
are barely glued together
maybe the yeah yeah there's doors work
like with like you can t tool you can
put in fixtures and furniture and doors
after the fact I think the main layout
of it and the different floors in the
structural integrity of it was made on a
small level and then later on he brought
in these are the questions and also what
happened to all glassware and rolling
chairs as soon as he picked that
building alright yeah even if you
secured it that's that you can't yeah
magnets these are the questions that
drive us well let us know what you think
in the comments below and again check
out our breakdown of all the other stuff
you might have missed in the trailer and
Reinert just subscribe to new rockstars
to stay up to date on all the stuff you
missed in your favorite Marvel movies
thanks everybody